the Samsung Galaxy s3 is probably the
most wanted Android phone of the entire
year 2012 Samsung has delivered so
without any further ado let's go ahead
and take a look at the full review so
this is Samsung's flagship device
worldwide so it deserves flagship worthy
hardware and it gets exactly that on the
inside of the United States version we
have a 1.5 gigahertz Snapdragon s4
dual-core processor and a huge 2 gigs of
RAM there's also a 4G radio inside and
it features expandable storage via
microSD all in a package that's just
eight point six millimeters thin and
Samsung has done something awesome and
made every carriers version identical to
each other so accessories will work on
all of the samsung galaxy s 3s in the
world and you can even exchange the
backs of them for a cool like white on
blue contrast look if you like and to
top off all the spec sheet stuff which
is actually detailed here on the back of
the boxes you get software wise Android
4.0.4 Ice Cream Sandwich with the latest
version of Samsung's TouchWiz UX on top
and we have some things to say about
that too the biggest new feature of the
mall literally is the new display it's a
four point eight inch HD Super AMOLED
display so 1280 by 720 an absolutely
gorgeous display for a phone is it
pentile yes but can you tell nope I mean
this is a crystal-clear super high
contrast display with amazing
responsiveness thanks to what's
underneath a lot of people toss around
the word pentile as if that means
instant death to display but it's
honestly you really can't tell unless
you're looking at a much lower
resolution of a pentile display first
thing you notice when you're playing
around with the galaxy s3 is what I like
to call fluidity the smoothness of the
user interface when you're flying around
TouchWiz it's literally unmatched by any
other Android phone I've been playing
with the One X for a while the Galaxy
Nexus for a while but these animations
here all execute at perfectly high frame
rates and that's not something I can say
for every other Android device and it
just adds to that fluid experience
there's not a stutter anywhere and this
is the one reason why if I had to pick
an Android skin over pure Android it
would be TouchWiz I mean it's the
fastest it's the light
of them all couple that with the two
gigs of RAM in the galaxy s3 and you're
looking at a pretty freakin fast device
TouchWiz is also one of the least
obtrusive in-your-face android skins
that there are so the user experience is
pretty close to stock Android there are
a few minor changes like the settings
menu in that notification battery
percentage indicator another thing is
they replace the stock calendar widget
and app with their own Samsung themed
one which is very different looking
there are a few other pre-installed
Samsung applications too and depending
on which carrier you go with in the
United States you'll get a few more
pre-installed application one thing that
I actually found a little bit annoying
is that the toggles in the notification
area while they are really really handy
and I'm glad that they're there the
slide in animation that happens every
time I pull down the notification tray
like is that really necessary I'll have
a Wi-Fi toggle is all the way on the
left and it slides in from the left so
that prevents me from being able to
immediately toggle Wi-Fi like right when
I pull it down so it's just a little bit
annoying maybe just a minor complaint I
suppose but something definitely worth
mentioning the toggles themselves are
pretty much all really useful and I'm
really glad that their product TouchWiz
definitely one of my favorite features
now that three button layout at the
bottom some people love it some people
really hate it actually some people
don't like the home button that's
physical at all
honestly really grew on me though
actually after about five days of using
the phone I kind of liked it the the
soft buttons disappear when they're not
in use you know they perform legacy
functions but they aren't there when you
don't need them so that's pretty cool
you can access the multitasking still by
long pressing that home button so
honestly if you play with it and you
don't like it at all give it some time
you might actually find that you like it
in the end overall there is a ton of
Samsung stuff built in to the software
TouchWiz that I could never cover like
smart stay and keeps the phone on when
you're looking at it in motion and all
this stuff but honestly most of it is
pretty gimmicky s-voice which is a
freaking Siri clone of all things can be
just as useless as Siri sometimes hi
galaxy what is the capital of France
didn't do anything like the lockscreen
though which gives you the option to
drag in apps to open them immediately
and it gives you the ability to pick
which apps you have here nice touch
I always like the ability to open the
camera quickly and speaking of camera
the galaxy s3 has an amazing camera it
blows the Galaxy Nexus is camera out of
the water and impressed me more than the
One X's shooter I like saying shooter
but it's an eight megapixel shooter on
the back it takes 1080p video it has
sharp autofocus it performs well in low
light which is great it takes stunning
pictures for a phone and is totally
capable of replacing your
point-and-shoot ok hear that you no
longer need to bring another camera on
vacation or something you can literally
just bring your phone I'm really happy
it's gotten to this level of quality the
quality is great the pictures and the
features are aplenty and it's fast it's
really really fast there's a burst mode
which can take like 20 pictures in a
couple of seconds it's awesome very easy
to use also up front there's a 1.9
megapixel front-facing camera for stuff
like Google+ Hangouts and Skype and face
unlock nice so is it a worthy flagship
from Samsung it really is it's got the
internals to support everything you
throw at it from gaming to everyday you
store to just heavy applications the
battery life you get out of this is more
than acceptable again miles better than
the Galaxy Nexus you can get all-day out
of this guy easily and while the design
may not be everyone's favorite that it
feels fine in the hand
there's Gorilla Glass 2 on the front the
device itself is very thin no need for a
screen protector with that Gorilla Glass
and the removable back gives you access
to the internals the 2100 milliamp hour
battery the sim card the SD card and
this is something I never understand why
people complain about the battery door
being flexible because you should just
put it back on the phone I've never seen
one break under normal use anything you
throw at this it can handle this phone
is a boss it's one of the biggest and
one of the baddest of them all it's the
galaxy s3 so to launch such an awesome
device on pretty much every US carrier
and then some that would be Verizon
t-mobile Sprint AT&T and US Cellular
they held some pretty awesome launch
occasions or parties or something like
that launch events and I went to one
that was in New York City and I got a
lot of Awesome footage from that where
they were talking about the device where
they were launching it what I were
excited for it it was kind of their own
version of a keynote they even poked fun
at their competitors like some other
companies have been known to do one of
our primary competitors like today we
feel is a holiday event of their device
is the little more than launch the
software program and that's a great one
three devices that most manufacturers
would be Iceland
and that was actually the first time
where I was able to see a u.s. variant
of the galaxy s3 actually saw a whole
bunch of them lined up together they all
had back-to-back their carrier branding
on the back so it's pretty cool to see
the Verizon version in person even
though it's actually technically not
released yet so there you go the galaxy
s3 is obviously a really really good
device it's very impressive device to me
both on paper because the specs are
awesome it has 2 gigs of RAM
you know the LTE for the Verizon and
Sprint versions everything like that
it's just a really great all-around
device and I'm the experience on the
other hand is also really good and for
me it's actually enough to get me to
switch from the Nexus to the galaxy s3
on Verizon as my full-time carry daily
device so let me know what you guys
think of it obviously you can give a
thumbs up on this video if you enjoyed
it but do you guys think that the Galaxy
s3 is better than the other flagship
devices out there I can obviously
compare it to the HTC One X if you like
because that's obviously another
quad-core device overseas compared to
the quad-core version of this so let me
know what you guys think if I should do
some comparisons either way thank you
for watching this video and I will talk
to you guys next